foreign
ladies and gentlemen counselors members
of the public uh welcome to
torridge internal oversight and scrutiny
committee
um
before we start I would remind all
counselors please and officers that if
you are speaking it is essential that
your microphone is switched on and then
is Switched Off when you've finished
because there is a capacity it will only
allow two to operate at a time those of
us who watch CNR on YouTube last night
fifty percent of the meeting was lost
because
um microphones were not switched on so
um
please ensure that your microphone is
switched on
um
could we have apologies for absence
please Kirsty
[Music]
thank you
moving on to the minutes as published
and I will first of all for accuracy
purposes
um we will
go through Page by page please shout if
there's you have something to say and
then when we've completed if anybody's
got a comment that they want to say then
again we can take that so accuracy to
start with on the agenda Pages page
three
page four
page five
Page Six
and Page seven
anybody wishing or having a comment on
those
can I have a proposal that those are
correct
councilor Hudson
and I will second from the chair
always in favor that there's a correct
record
not too unanimous
uh
moving on to the
action list
which is a gender item three
um
running through the the first one social
value group terms of reference executive
uh was going to speak to Sean Kearney
uh thanks excuse me thanks Chad um
actually spoke to our state's manager uh
yesterday John Wayne and if members are
minded to John can attend the your next
meeting and Report
I think that would be welcomed as a as a
as an initial
um brief on that and then we can later
on look if we want to delve into more
detail thank you for that uh
um the uh date for the Estuary strategy
um to come to committee again in the
absence of John are we looking at uh
um John I haven't caught up with John
John must leave for my leave overlapped
so John's away till next week I I came
back last week in John's way so uh chair
I'll catch up with him when he's back
next week
so we're happy to leave that underneath
that's fine
um
we have a
and finally the uh
me there was a meeting held to my myself
the chair John Walter and
um Gordon
um where we amongst other things
discussed
um uh the
how we can look at Future enforcement
and again I'll talk about that later
that is a a gender item
um
it's not on the action plan
um but there was a question about the
peer review and I think the leader and
the chief executive are going to update
us at some point I don't know if there
is an update yet
um chair is going to find out there's
one other item on the action list as
well in fact lendology yeah uh sorry
yeah absolutely
said should I do with both let's deal
with both good items so so the action
list 256 is the medium external uh or we
would need tomorrow so that'll be the
opportunity to consider bringing that
into the forward plan and obviously the
chair of extra JavaScript news here
today so I'll ask Stacey to pick that up
at the meeting tomorrow
um with the the peer review yes we've
been having discussions with the the
local government Association and it's in
plan and preparation uh for next year we
haven't got specific time frames
push anything at this meeting before
we've discussed it with the wider
membership so there will be one
um probably next year
if if you could uh let us know as and
when that decision is taken that's that
that's fine thank you
um
moving on public contributions
um I'm not aware of any no we have no
public contributions Declarations of
interests counselors uh you're all aware
of the requirement to
put up your hand and say if you have an
interest in an item we are discussing in
any way I have no urgent matters to
bring forward from the chair
and we have no items into uh item number
eight carbon neutral Target 2030
um update from the climate and
sustainability officer
so hi good afternoon and for those of
you that have not met me my name's Donna
I'm the sustainability and climate
officer for torridge and North Devon
councils so it's a joint post between
the two authorities
um so just a quick reminder on what the
torridge district council commitments
are in 2019 the council declared a
climate emergency
um
through that they basically said as an
organization our carbon emissions will
be Net Zero by 2030 and the district's
carbon emissions will be Net Zero by
2050 which is in line with the UK
government Target
so that's that's what we've signed up to
as an organization
um I started a couple of years ago one
of the main reasons for employing me was
to do the carbon footprint for the
council and we've only had two so far
I'm just working on the third one
um so I can give an update to the group
at some point um by October I should
have the third carbon footprint so you
can see the Baseline in 2020-21 is a bit
of an odd Baseline here because that was
in the midst of covid so we had
lockdowns and that obviously affected
the council's operations but that was
that was the Baseline year that was
chosen and the um
the total carbon footprint for the
council was just under 4 000 tons of
carbon dioxide equivalents in a year
the 2021-22 carbon footprint went up
that's partly because we'd come out of
covered and it was a more normal year
for the council
um but it's mainly down to the way that
we do the scope three emissions so sorry
for for people that don't know much
about carbon footprinting scope one
emissions are the fuels that you burn on
site so that's either gas or oil or
biomass up at cads down and it's also
the fuel that we use in our vehicles
scope 2 is electricity
the scope 3 is everything else and that
includes procured goods and services so
all of the councils spend I convert into
a carbon factor it's a very crude
calculation it's the best one we've got
that's free
um and basically the more money you
spend the the bigger your carbon
footprint so it's not something that I'm
going to continue doing every year
but
um the Council of climate change working
group needs to have a discussion about
the the those scope three emissions and
particularly our procured goods and
services and
give me a steer on how as a council they
want me to report that in the future has
anyone got any questions about this
slide
okay
so scope one two and three is it's
technical terms I don't find it
particularly helpful when talking to
people about carbon Footprints so I
prefer to talk about property transport
and and spend
so um the Baseline for our property
emissions so that's the gas that we use
in our buildings and the electricity
it's 423 tons of carbon dioxide
equivalent
so
um
projecting forward to 2030
we need to save about just under 50 tons
of carbon diox equivalent every year if
we're to achieve Net Zero for our
properties
we've had energy surveys done
and I've been able to identify potential
energy savings that we could make so by
2025 I think 20 reduction through
investing in Energy Efficiency would be
reasonable if the projects are approved
and by 2027 I think we could get an
additional 35 reduction through
investing in switching from gas or oil
to electricity and also through
investing in renewable energy as a
council so
um putting more solar panels on the
roofs of our buildings for example
and then by 2030 we could get an
additional 35 reduction through through
doing more of the same and then that
would probably leave about 10 to offset
in some way
transport is really tricky our transport
carbon footprint is nearly all the waste
and recycling lorries and because we're
a large rural district and we've got
Hills the electric waste and recycling
lorries that you might see in Glasgow or
Kensington
aren't suitable we've trialled one and
the drivers loved it because it was
brand new and sparkly and but it
wouldn't get out the hill out of
Biddeford so it's not something that I'm
going to be recommending to the council
or indeed trying to persuade Richard
haste to invest in at all
so
um there is no solution for our waste
and recycling Fleet at the moment in
terms of switching from Diesel and
whenever Richard buys a new vehicle he
makes sure it's it's the the best that
he can in terms of diesel performance
but you know it's still a diesel vehicle
so there isn't a solution we're
potentially looking at hydrogen and
there's a project
bubbling along in the background with
Chris Fuller
and some external partners that may
enable us to do some hydrogen trials and
or
electric vehicles May improve to the
point well you know
well yeah I know I mean
if you talk to some of the electric
vehicle manufacturers they say that they
will have a solution but um yeah I think
hydrogen is probably the way forward so
um so transport's really tricky and all
I'm suggesting at the moment for
transport is that the smaller vans that
we use in environment protection in
parking services that when they come up
for Renewal that we should switch to EBS
then because EV technology for those
sorts of vehicles is proven we have a
charging point at Riverbank that we can
use there's going to be charging points
going into the new environment Center as
far as understand it
and um yeah so and we've obviously got
charging around the district in car
parks and so on
and then finally
the procured goods and services
um we need to save about 143 tons of
carbon dioxide every year
if we're to achieve net Sierra there and
this is actually just really tricky and
you know there aren't lots of carbon
neutral products for us to buy as a
council
um we don't even really understand the
carbon impacts of the stuff that we're
buying so I'm proposing to do some work
with our major suppliers and we're doing
this in partnership with Devon County
Council and the University of Exeter uh
Bristol City and a couple of other local
authorities
um
and it we are going to have to offset to
achieve Net Zero particularly for our
procured goods and services but um tree
planting is not going to give
us all of the offsetting that we need
and so again the the solutions
to reach Net Zero by 2030 aren't all in
place but they are being worked on the
biospheres looking at um
offsetting projects through the natural
Capital Marketplace and I'm also talking
to 361 energy about offsetting projects
that we could do either through domestic
retrofit or working with businesses on
their scope one and two emissions
so it's slightly vague in terms of what
we need to do to get to 2030 the
property side is well established and we
just need to find the money to do it
which is obviously no easy challenge in
these uh tricky financial times for the
council so
yeah if anyone's got any questions very
happy to take them
Donald thank you for that
um
questions
nice short concise headline
um brief there which was actually most
welcome
um
councilor craigie
yeah I was just going to ask about the
transport have you explored the use of
waste oils for biodiesel because
obviously if it's waste and recycling of
some animal fats to produce a mix to
reduce the
the mineral content of the diesel would
be helpful
and also what sort of level of this the
social procurement policy do you think
is going to help reduce the carbon
content of the scope 3.
yeah so um The National Trust have
actually got a trial on hvo which is the
the vegetable oil fuel locally and we've
been following that quite closely and
it's worked very well in the boiler at
Arlington house and it's not worked very
well in their vehicles and Richard is
understandably reluctant to allow me to
start playing about with his waste and
recycling lorries and potentially
breaking them so um it's a it's an
ongoing discussion it's not one we've
discounted but um insurance companies
are starting to get a bit uh
nervous
perhaps it's the right word a bit
nervous about hvo in in Goods vehicles
and so on because there have been some
issues and certainly The National Trust
at Arlington ran into insurance issues
with their hvo trial so yeah it's an
ongoing discussion with Richard and I've
got to admit
we've not really done too much on it
just because the finances at the council
are really tricky and spend more money
on an HBO trial at the time it just
didn't seem to be a priority but I'm
very happy to have another look at it
and in terms of the social value policy
how much that is going to drive
progress towards our Net Zero targets
the answer is I don't know because I'm
not sure what the policy is going to
involve at the moment I'm obviously
quite Keen that it does look at Carbon
reductions and carbon emissions But
ultimately it's going to be a decision
for counselors to make as to what we put
in that policy but yes I think there are
things that we can do through
procurement and we're starting to see
that certainly with the capital projects
you know Adrian weather has got a really
good handle on the embodied carbon
emissions associated with development
and then the the sort of the operational
ones and I don't need to worry about our
capital projects I know that Adrian and
Chris will will do that utmost to
minimize emissions as far as practical
but it there are costs associated with
all of this and obviously construction
costs are just going through the roof
so you know there's that balance isn't
there
um
so yeah on the construction side it's
good
um start to come through and some of the
purchasing Adrian Avery has been looking
at play equipment at Victoria Park he
managed to get a carbon
footprint associated with the product
and you know he's people are starting to
think about this internally I think
having social value policy and the
training for officers around that will
just embed it more widely across the
council
give people a steer when they're maybe
not so sure what it means
uh thank you Donna they you were
speaking to the the right not sure where
the horse's mouth got anything to say
yet but
um it will eventually start to to speak
um interestingly from my
um indeed I'll come to you uh councilor
bushby um
in within the agricultural sector and
the work that I've seen in the
agricultural sector with regard to
in fact the heavy Goods operation the
science just does not support it and at
the moment you cannot get
uh load as in burden placed on a machine
power consumption and and energy storage
you know in other but it just
scientifically does not add up at the
moment and the agricultural Machinery
sector at the moment are not looking at
electricity or electrical power because
the science just doesn't doesn't work so
I can understand that I think hvo is
widely accepted as a good heating oil
and there's lots of there's lots of
groups and cartels around the country
who are using doing that I've also heard
that it's there are problems with using
it in in combustion engines which is
different quite different from from
heating heating boilers and things
um
councilor bushby you had a question
thank you chair just a bit of
information information for Donna the uh
if you look at JCB as a manufacturer
um they are that they've been for the
last two years trial and hydrogen
vehicles
um on site and you know in large
quantities and apparently the results
are very good you may want to just look
at that but there is another large
haulage company in in the UK that's had
a
a fleet of vehicles converted to
hydrogen and they've been trialing that
for the last two years
so it's you know it's new technology you
know generally but there are lots of
Trials going on around the country some
quite successful
yeah hydrogen definitely is a really
significant interest to storage and
North Devon because obviously both
authorities are in a very similar
position and we would need a source of
hydrogen to be generated locally to make
it worthwhile and that's that's that's
the tricky bit at the moment but as I
said there is a project in the pipeline
that potentially if it gets funding
might help with that I was just going to
finish here that in in terms of getting
our overall carbon footprint down
footprint down
um I think we're on a bit of hiding to
nothing because everything we do uh
on at Orange
adds to that carbon footprint every time
we pass a plan on application for 500
houses for 200 hours it adds to that
carbon footprint so we will be
increasing it far quicker and we can
ever reduce it
um I had a has anybody else got a
question for Donna they I had a further
question or two part really presumably
from your chart we don't have a we don't
have a baseline before 2021 because
nobody was really capturing the data is
that is that right
yeah there used to be a national
indicator Steve probably knows more
about this than me because I only
started working for a local Authority a
couple years ago but I it vaguely
remember that there was a national
indicator 185 or something like that
that was that was a carbon footprint and
toridge used to report that but
unfortunately the
the data behind it is no longer in the
authority and the officer who did it
also is no longer in the authority and
and whatever he did it's not it's not
comparable so there is some data but I I
couldn't tell you what went into that so
that's why we've got that Baseline year
of 2020 2021 which again as you pointed
out as a result we need to be cautious
of because that being a covid year was
not a typical year for for
um our carbon usage
um or carbon creation my other question
for you Donna is are you in your
position and you're wrong uh are you
tasked with assessing the cost in
financial terms of any of the reduction
measures that you are proposing or is
that for other people to put a financial
cost I think that that will be done on a
project by project basis so I I couldn't
tell you how much it's going to cost us
and we've got some idea
of particularly on the property side
investing in Energy Efficiency I mean
given Energy prices at the moment it
would save the authority money and
certainly that's what other District
councils are finding and so there are
definitely some projects where we'd
spend to save and there are other
projects
where it is just going to be a cost
um but yeah I don't I don't know it
would be on a project by project basis
so if it was my project then yes I'd be
responsible but otherwise it'd be
somebody like you know potentially John
Wynn on the property side
uh thank you for that any other question
yes councilor kotlin
those brands are there
um so there's something called the
public sector decarbonisation scheme and
it's a annual funding round
um at the moment they're really focused
on heat pumps so if you apply to them
and you're very lucky you may get some
money to install a heat pump and then
they'll give you some money off the back
of it to install solar panels that
enables you to run that heat pump and
it's incredibly competitive and the
money goes within minutes
so um
we've not made a bid at torridge partly
because we didn't have all of the
surveys for our buildings and so on and
partly just
um resources in the major projects team
they've been asked to focus on housing
with the last Council
and and obviously with a new environment
Center or sorry it's not the environment
Center anymore is it operational so I'm
I'm never going to remember that I'm
going to be environment Center in 2050.
um yeah so with the new uh operational
service center then and they've got
quite a lot on their plate but I
understand that we have been talking to
the three Leisure centers about
potentially bidding for some money and I
don't know much more about that I've got
a meeting about that in a minute
so I'd answer that bit so there's been
two rounds of leisure funding that's
been announced one closed a number of
weeks ago which was submitted a bid for
and one opened yesterday which is
probably the one John has got a meeting
with about I will be seeking to where
there's opportunity so a bid forward for
funding through that and that's around
heat Energy Efficiency at leisure
centers
we've all done that Donna thank you very
much indeed for that and for for coming
to the the committee today
um
okay moving on
the need for this committee to approve
the terms of reference for the social
value task and finish group I'd actually
miss the fact when I was reading through
things this morning I sent an email out
to councilor craigie and Mr dengate um
saying where was it and they said look
at the look at the agenda that's it
um actually when you look at it it it's
a very short concise and and actually
entirely descriptive piece as it says
there on our agenda to draft this is the
task for them to draft a social value
policy that is linked to the council's
Strategic priorities
is measurable um but that actually is is
lovely and short and as far to me hits
the right buttons
any comment
question or um suggestion on that
is everybody happy with that
right
um do we need to vote on that or uh yes
please could I I um
I I I propose propose that that that is
the terms of reference for our task and
finish group and that's a unanimous
group thank you very much
um good uh now to the
um
the the biggest ticket on a day I
wouldn't I wouldn't say in priority time
terms more important than anything else
but the biggest ticket which is uh
um review of the quarterly business
return
um for the first quarter before we start
before I hand over to Gordon um
the um you will have seen that I um
first of all encouraged the the direct
circulation of the report to all
councilors rather than them having to go
to look for it and secondly I invited
all councilors uh to ask questions if
they wanted to and I
stood ready to claw back from that if
necessary if if officers were overrun
with with duplicate questions in fact uh
there's a good good crop of questions
that this period uh and and so far I'm
pleased with it
um I would also say at this point
councilor Pennington who is on holiday
at the moment phoned me from Sweden he
also fantastic I think
um phoned me from Sweden this morning to
thank officers for their work and
detailed responses to section 151
officer and for his presentation on the
first part of the qbr
yes thank you chair so this is the first
report this year brought before the
internal scrutiny committee and it looks
at both financial and non-financial
performance for the year the
presentation is split into two parts
I'll be doing the latter part which
concentrates on the finances and my
colleague Anna who is new to the council
will be bringing you through the
non-financial data
thank you
thank you and I just wanted to show you
some things that the council are doing
really well
um this is before we start we do
benchmarking which I know John talked
about at the June meeting and the
councils that we Benchmark against are
here they're um done by the chartered
Institute of Public Finance can I just
hold you there I mean we're just going
to try to pull out screen back because
councilors on that side aren't able to
actually see it bro what is that is that
as far back as it'll go though
is that right
sorry about that okay oh my God oh my
God don't worry I was in full flow then
so it's the chartered Institute of
Public Finance and accountancy that uses
um some measures and it's to do with the
size of the authority and its rurality
and social economic factors and so I
just thought that would be to show you
where they are within the country
um so I have done some benchmarking for
you and I'm just picked out a few of the
highlights of the report
um the prosperity fund is is for capital
projects for small businesses and
Community infrastructure so hopefully
it'll help strengthen the rural economy
within our area
um there has been some high-profile
events for the Apple door clean
Maritime Innovation Center
all the invoices have been paid within
terms and the trio of Summer retail
pictures there's been a bit of an issue
which somebody has been in the questions
anyway
um with reporting low foot full but
that'll come within the questions
and also this was a question too
actually the high proportion of people
in torridge that are claiming Universal
credit which has been benchmarked you
can see there that we're quite High
and that's that's going to be a question
later as well
so theme two which is communities health
and housing
and the household support fund has been
helping residents within torrage with
the cost of living crisis
[Music]
um
there has been a greater success in
preventing homelessness and there's been
a 69 success rate this year compared
with 41 last year
um so that's on that's in an improvement
um The Plow Arts Center has got their
funding
and there's we're higher than Target
with the number of people living in
temporary accommodation but that's to do
with the supply of housing that's in the
qbr as well
um but you know we're not the highest
but we are still quite high and I know
homeless hope people and homes is always
going to be a big issue which is why
it's there
so and the environment
um Westwood home Beach obviously the
blue flag Beach for the 20th consecutive
year which is good
um there's flood Defense work going to
go on at the Kenworth Valley Nature
Reserve and the picture there is it's
very small but it's of children at the
bio Blitz at Northern Burrows where they
found a record number of
um new species it saw 268 school
children and 190 members of the public
coming in for a 24-hour period
and the benchmarking to do with the
environment is the recycling it remains
High and the garden waste is growing
every year
and finally the council our Council
so we've obviously a new new Council
were elected in May
and the torrage planning team were
highly commended they were recognized
for their significant investment in
training and willingness to support new
staff
which is always good and the planning
decisions timeline remains within
targets
council tax collection is above Target
and I've just put the England average
there which is much lower than any of
our benchmarking councils
which I thought was worth pointing out
thank you now over to Gordon
uh this first table highlights traded
income and this is shown because it's
particularly volatile and there's some
particularly large numbers and there
aren't any key numbers there to draw
your attention to in terms of areas of
concern we're informed that planning
income is due to catch-up and the
particularly large areas such as car
parking income are on target
another key area for the council is
salaries and that's again because it's
such a large area of expense around 10
million pounds a year and we are there
are a number of vacancies at the minute
but of course there's a there's a
relatively small under spend on salaries
on on permanent staffings but there is
an increasing agency costs as well
so the next tables on this slide
um show the summary position for for the
revenue budget so that that middle table
looks at the the summary
um underspend in terms of the service
split of the council and that shows the
net variance of 473
000 under spend and then those next two
tables show both a list of those key and
large overspends and vendorspins
obviously the large underspend that's
been mentioned previously is from
interest receivable because interest
rates have gone up such a lot since the
since the assumptions in the budget were
were set that that the that we're now
looking at around 1.2 million pounds
worth of interest to be received this
year this is obviously going to be very
handy but not a source of funding that
we can rely upon in the future
and of course in terms of the overspend
the key area there is Staff costs we
budgeted five percent uh increase on
Staffing budgets for this year
it now looks very likely that the award
will be on average
um possibly seven percent but possibly
um even even more in excess of that so
that's our estimate as at the end of
June
um as to what's the increase in Staffing
costs will be um for for uh for this
current year
so yeah so that this slide just refers
to some of those areas of movement and
also it refers to the software costs
and some of the Hostile income is below
where we anticipated it being as well
so then this table shows the capital
budgets as of this year so we had a
capital program for 23 24 of 13.3
million a lot of this is weighted
towards the operational Services Center
and the maritime Innovation Center and
obviously as those have yet to take off
a lot of the spend has yet to occur so
at the end of June there's only just
over 1 billion pounds worth of spend but
the approvals of course will stay there
but when the spend does occur and this
is common in capital projects that that
things can take longer to deliver than
anticipated
and then this final slide just looks at
our anticipated use of reserves in the
current year so you can see that we're
starting the year with 13.1 million
um and of course the other key points
draw your attention to there is a large
number of commitments that we do have
against our reserves so in reality 13
million men may sound like a lot but of
course they are
very much committed to particular
Capital schemes
and this is just shown for information
though we we mentioned earlier that
there's a large anticipated receipt of
interest on our deposits this year and
this just shows where our cash deposits
are currently lent out to in line with
our treasury management policy
thank you chair
thank you Ron um
questions on that before we go into
looking at the specific questions that
have been uh asked and have been
circulated in the supplement any comment
or question on what's being said so far
councilor bushby
which out not on the actual financials
but if we go right back to the start of
the slide
um you mentioned the three spaces that
we've got on the Riverside which we
haven't yet been able to
find any tenants for the main reason for
that from what I understand is that the
um the pitches have to be vacated each
night so if someone comes along with a
horse box or a trailer
it just uses a coffee stall or whatever
they have to remove it at the end of the
evening well that's totally impractical
that's never ever going to happen so if
we're going to make this a success we
need to change the rules so that they
can leave them there obviously securely
locked up but at least they're there for
the season or whatever but to ask anyone
to remove them
every night at the end of business is
totally impractical
um which I remember a specific answer
for that there'll be something for our
state's team so if you put it on the
action list and the states managers
attended their next meeting then you can
pick it up then that's okay
moving to the uh
submitted questions
for qbr
which has been and we'll go through them
now
um
the the
the the first one was was councilor
Pennington
um uh asking about the statistics for
the uptake of the household support fund
and he was directed to
um the uh well was was he was asking
the level of exposure and publicity that
we were giving it and
Stacey Dory has directed him to the
online advertisements that we have and
um uh happy with that any comment there
um
likewise
councilor Pennington asked for the if we
had a monthly breaks fully partly or
refused for the household support fund
um and uh again the grant officer has
produced a table showing for the
different uh household support fund uh
issues three four a and 4B
and the dates over which they ran and
the value and the amount that is
remaining
um
so interesting again as we were saying
the other day uh for the for the one
four a that finishes uh on the 30th of
September so 30th of this month at the
time of producing this this response
there's still some thirty thousand
pounds available in that fund
um not currently claimed
um
I think the point on the on the right
hand column of the the last but one is
that if you look at successful
applications
and indeed add also the refusals to that
because those were our applications even
those so
um that tells me that
the word is out there and people are
being informed and people you know there
are that you will always come across
somebody who says they don't know about
something but that doesn't necessarily
reflect
um the the general view
um
any
any comment on anybody have any comment
on that one no uh yeah councilor Hodgson
I I'm not 100 sure uh we've had the
allocation is for the year that's why
it's shown
um for a f4a and f4b so we had an
allocation of the only split uh between
the two halves
um obviously it's so 170 000 over six
months so it's kind of thirty thousand
pounds per month so the amount left is
probably consistent with a monthly spend
but I haven't I'll find out the answer
to your question Council Hudson and uh
we'll circulate that because obviously
that by the next meeting that will be
too late for an answer
and thank you because historically
there's been a fund called the
discretionary housing payments and if
that wasn't fully spent we were actually
penalized the following uh Financial
year in a reduction in what they
allocated us so I wouldn't want this to
be seen as us not allocating the full
amount I think we've done a really good
job of advertising this household
support fund
um but I will draw to attention that
members have actually been provided with
posters with the ability to share this
with their communities so it's up to us
to make sure our communities are fully
aware of what's open because on the key
um and the response by the state's
officer
um
confirms what has happened that there's
been trial trial licenses
um
they haven't actually particularly
traded particularly well in terms of
number of days
the charge
um
is it what I didn't know is that 350
pounds 360 pounds plus vat for each
pitch
for three months or per day
for the three-month period
um
and then also an electrical water jug
I think with all of this the
the question is what why are you what
what are you trying to achieve by doing
that are you actually trying to do this
as a as a direct Revenue generating
exercise or is it actually an indirect
exercise to attract more people to use
the key come on to the key and that
indirectly it enhances the the economy
and also the use of of the place in a
more General sense
um because
um I mean we've had
um
comments in the past about that the cost
especially for a small
Traders the cost have been on the key
we've then heard a comment about having
to pack up and shut up shop and and
clear out every night
um and it
to me doesn't sound a particularly
viable trading trading model if that's
the right way of putting it not that I'm
an expert but um I'd take
comment or view first of all um Mr
Harper come back on your
I think the response you had already
saying that uh someone's put in for
three months and used the pitch for two
or two couple of days and the other one
was
um for 10 days I think that says it all
and then clearly one of the people
saying there's just no footfall along
the key side so if we're going to do
something like this it has to be thought
through I don't I'm not sure whether it
was just three pitches that's a good
idea rather than saying there's three
pictures there how do we actually
integrate this if you go on the
continent you look at the keysights and
places in the continent it's absolutely
a mass with people like people selling
fish and that's always been my point
we've got something with the water and
we've got no fish sales
this started um
a couple of years back when one of the
local cafes who trades on the key
um
approached orange to see whether they
could actually put a horse box
Cafe type thing uh on the key side
because they they thought there was a
um an element of trade that they were
actually missing from people that
actually walk you know right on the edge
of the key
for that one summer but they um as I
said the downside was I had to remove
that every night at the end of at the
end of uh you know their trading which
meant they haven't been back since but I
think as a an offshoot of that officers
probably thought well why don't we put
three
um
parking spaces there to attract some
additional
footfall to the key which you know
improves it for everyone and at the same
time uh produces a you know a bit of
additional revenue for the council it's
win-win as long as they're there and
being at the the issue of how long you
know alone then to be there overnight it
may well be a better takeout
uh Jay I think Council bushby's kind of
indicator of ours and say Obviously it
was a trial to to establish uh what
might work and considering the feedback
I've seen it probably weren't a further
look and I said obviously the purpose of
having a trial so I think it was uh
going back to your comments at the star
chair it was that dual purpose was made
uh potential for some Revenue in camber
obviously it's not a huge sum but just
kind of generating for making use of a
of a public area
um which is a good place for things like
that which obviously a trial has taken
place and the team will have a look at
the results of that and consider what to
do
um for the future
just very quickly I think what we've got
to do is if we're having Traders there
we've got to have a better tourist offer
along the Riverside because all right
you might like to stop and have a coffee
or buy some fish but after you've done
that up the keysight or do they go
up and go into Mill Street
um and I think it's about combining that
tourist offer as to what Riverside
activities we could have whether we I
know there's been sort of ideas about
the harbor and what we could do with
that I think you need to combine the two
I don't think you can just say well it's
not working
you've got to make sure you're offering
people something else as well as these
opportunities and I think then you will
attract the Traders as well
thank you
Council great yeah I just like to sort
of echo that you do kind of need a
critical mass when you're dealing with
with anything that attracts got a
sufficient hook to draw people in and
and get people there because that sort
of area of the key you don't really need
to visit at all
um you know when you're going through
town or even walking from town to
Victoria Park or the car Parks you you
don't have to use that route at all so
there's no sort of apart from people
specifically just wanting to look at the
river
they won't be using that so there needs
to be something that draws their
attention to it to get them a good
viable football
I think as the feedback to the trial
because we can we we we should we we can
input
um just from our own discussion size
um trade is always going to be nervous
about creating additional competition to
themselves but if a part of your
strategy you actually incentivize
current Traders uh in the
um
in the Town Center to actually have
satellite uh locations out there and you
you you incentivize them
um perhaps initially for a trial period
giving them free pitch or whatever and
you therefore have this critical mass
that you're talking about and also you
look very carefully at what the mix is
why would I want to walk over that I
want to get a coffee I want to get an
ice cream actually by doing that and
then going to see something else that I
want to buy as well or I'm attractive
but you need a hook to get people to go
over there in the first place and that
needs strategy and it needs somebody
not alike to me but somebody who
understands uh the the the retail
offering business together with perhaps
some some local shopkeeping shop people
to actually come together and work out
how best to make it work and then to get
it launched and off the ground we as a
council should be
sympathetic and
entrepreneurial in the sense that we
should we should help that after a while
if it gets established yes then we start
possibly to take a bit of money from it
but um initially it's all about actually
greater use of the key it's about
creating another thing for people to do
if they come into town which we
frequently say you know there is a
shortage of that so it but it's it's how
you go about it now this sort of thing
needs a specific strategy and plan
counselor kotlin you um could move the
Hopkins ice cream van and put that next
to it and I might attract football
well he could you know they they they
they they we we we they could have more
of that
um or whatever so as I said I I'm I'm
not uh the person for the detail but uh
it strikes me that it needs to be
brought together with with people are
involved people who know uh with a Clear
Vision uh and then you actually go out
and try to encourage that uh by engaging
uh not only with the mobile fraternity
but actually also with people who are
already trading on High Street now and
and in on the front there and say how
would you like to have in the summer
um a satellite uh business out there so
anyway there we go
yes indeed
I don't know if counselor bushby knows
or or not whether the the bit of a
regeneration board are sort of looking
at this as well and supporting it
because I think that might be the best
Avenue to sort of develop that more
strategic uh plan and offering that they
can then suggest to torridge that uh
yeah
okay I guess there's two aspects there's
also the harbor board which is looking
at the use of the harbor area so there's
kind of two strands
I think we've done that one now moving
on
um
who is this again from Mr Harper
um observation the planning income is is
um below
um anticipated budget at the moment
planning manager uh says that it is
still expected to recover to the uh four
hopes on a few major applications
currently being discussed
um uh so
um
not much more we can do on that
calendar for larger ships for the
financial year uh Richard Hayes came
back and said no
there isn't
um
Mr Harper
I think last year the uh the harbor
board actually also the harbor lost
money and I think this is another way
we're going down the same route
it does seem a shame that we are you
we've got a facility there and it's not
being used I know they're looking
they're saying with the Waverly later on
but um
well we've got we've got the uh
Oldenburg and that uses mainly
elfracombe so I can hardly see them
using the uh the benefit Harbor as a
regular base
moving on
the Hostile income and the issues with
the suitability of hubblestone a wine
issue now and Adrian Redwood the major
projects manager comes back
um
says that uh
Sully house not completed until later
this month and hubblestone Road not yet
started and that it hadn't progressed
because we've been concentrating on
alternative modular solutions for the
Pines Lake site and that is the funding
for that has not materialized for the
Pines Lane site is that correct
so that will now shift the emphasis of
effort back onto the hubblestone scheme
it's you can't do everything all at the
same time and they were given Direction
by Council to concentrate on
a particular thing the Pines Lane
it didn't secure the funding required to
progress that so therefore
one switches your effort back onto your
next thing you can um I I can I can see
that you know maybe if I just adding a
little bit of clarity to that so
um in terms of the funding uh
essentially the goal posts removed so
the funding is still there but not in
the format that we were able to deliver
a scheme as approved by full Council
that's the the kind of top and bottom it
really uh chair and and members we are
still progressing with the the Sally
House part of the ski that was approved
by full Council and uh the major
projects manual on track but
unfortunately because of the change in
the funding requirements uh the Pines
Lane one isn't and now as it says
resources and stuff resources can be
directed to moving forward with the
Harborstone scheme
and just to fill in there further the
Sully house one is the additional three
pods isn't it that's right yeah
um
questions any further comment on that
moving on
um Again by Mr Harper staff vacancies
um
pointing out and as you can see there
um the Sarah AIDS the HR manager
um
says that
the
um
that it is in in place
there will always be churn there will
always be vacancies we know that we know
here that actually recruiting is often a
a real challenge
um and um so
um
um that that is um that is the update on
that are you happy there at the moment
Mr Harper good
um moving on to Performance highlights
um councilor Pennington plays a question
uh which was
um he asked a couple of good questions
here actually
um concerning planning
uh and uh people will have seen that the
um
x-links
um cable project
um that's the cable coming up the power
cable input power cable coming up from
undersea cable coming up from Morocco
um has the the developers have applied
to the government for it to be
classified as a national significant
infrastructure project
and that basically takes it away from
local Authority planning control
and is looked at on a national basis
because the in National terms the the
project or what it delivers would be
classified as being strategic
um
this is what developers have applied for
there isn't a there is the government
have not responded yet to my knowledge
you know is that right
um not as far as we're aware neither do
we know if the if the application's
actually been submitted and see the
newsletters since I think all members
probably got a copy of that indicated
the intention so they've expressed their
intent uh I'll come back in a minute and
so councilor Pennington has
um asked the uh question that um of
course had this been processed through
ourselves as the local planning
Authority uh we would have generated
fees and incomes from that and from a a
project of this size I would has to
suggest significant fees and income from
that by it potentially been taken away
from us and becoming a national level uh
thing he asked the question
um would we lose those fees
um
in the answer from the planning manager
there's a there's there's a little bit
of hesitancy but I think the answer
basically is yes we would lose a fees
okay I guess it's not a loss is
something we just haven't yeah yeah no
absolutely quite right we're not unable
to Avail ourselves off
um and then he asks a similar question
about uh would we lose business rates uh
on the converter station at Alva Disco
If again if that went ahead and if
um they applied and it did become a a
national significant infrastructure
project
um and um the
response was there that um
[Music]
it is it would still be
um output from
energy or of of wind or solar and
therefore
um there would almost certainly be some
form of business rates payable but quite
how the valuation office would break
that down and and apportion it
um it's far too early to speculate and
also very complex probably in the
construction of that
um so
slightly dipping into the area of the
unknown in that because it's very early
the application hasn't even been
submitted yet we don't even know whether
it would be accepted by to to compare it
with I think
um
before I come to you you come to the
Craig you had a question on it uh yeah
it was just that in receiving the
x-links September newsletter they they
claim I was just trying to find the
exact wording but that turret is
supported their application to um
national government for the
determination and I just wondered what
that support was
um I know Helen is currently looking
into that so I think he was recognizing
that yes it is a nationally significant
project and something that would be best
suited to be considered uh nationally I
guess the other flip side a bit I was
going to come on to
um was it does present the council with
it with an opportunity an opportunity to
present as not be the local planning
authority to really present what our
views of the project are without being
compromised through the the planning
process so yes I think something went
back to say from a
an organization
perspective determine application yes we
believe and support that it should be
nationally significant so I think that's
the terminology used
I think that's actually a very very good
point you raise there Steve that um we
would get the opportunity to to comment
on it in a in a in a much more open uh
way than if we were constrained by
having to be the local planning
Authority who was going to be having to
make decisions
um Etc
um uh interesting interesting point
um
moving on
um to questions free page four on
overspends can the agency costs be shown
as a separate amount or percentage of
total staff costs
and they said yes and this is
um uh grimbaton the accountant who says
um
yes it can be and currently agency costs
account for six percent of the total
salary related expenditure
um
I must say ft is just a reference
of course sorry
that's good
um and
I had a question ft for are we apologize
full-time equivalent yes
um as a rather rather than employer and
the second question was
um whether we could express
um Agency use as full-time equivalents
um and uh again
um makes a point there that um
usage goes up and down
um at different times of the year
um
and
um the as of the 30th of June
um the agency staff uh full-time
equivalent
including Grounds Maintenance and waste
who are high users of of agency
um was 25.
um
of which doing it in reverse sense 15 of
those would have been ground maintenance
and waste
question for that who was the question
Mr Dengue you got
thank you thank you
um yes so my understanding is that's in
addition to the 23
vacancies
so the total potentially vacancy rate is
more 18 or 12 including Refuge so it's
good to be able to watch the trend I
think that's really where I'm coming
from that we can see how much difficulty
there is to attract the staff to to the
council
and if if it can be included going
forward that that may not be something
we can immediately do but if we can
build it into being included
I mean I think it might be misleading if
you add the two together because because
you've got the vacancies on the one hand
and you've got the agency staff so
actually the agency staff are going to
be to a great extent filling the roles
that are unfilled within the Staffing
complement so
is perhaps misleading to add them
together
thank you
anybody else have comment on it
Stephen you're not looking entirely
happy with the response I follow but I'm
I'm not sure that would always be the
case I think there's probably an overlap
so I think really this is to try and go
a little bit beneath the surface to get
a clearer picture of how much the
vacancy level is running at and what's
that trending at and then see how much
the agencies having to be used because
obviously agency costs would have a an
increased impact on that so it it then
leads on to questions around attracting
recruiting retention
to to
develop that I
as well as the cost which is
specifically what you're looking at
um
I'd have an interest in the the work
requirement which is not covered so in
terms of vacancies and then you're
employing buying in agency to cover
those vacancies
or are you able to cover all those
vacancies actually how much is left that
we would want to fill we can't fill but
with permanent and we can't even buy an
agency to cover and therefore what is is
there a shortfall of our capacity in
terms there as well which takes a bit
deeper but but not for now group
probably can't uh counter Craig it
yeah it strikes me that that act this is
actually a perfect one for a Venn
diagram basically of the the number of
vacancies the the amount of agency staff
brought in and how much is that agency
staff covering the vacancies and how
much is it just filling in for the
ordinaries you know the absences of or
existing staff I think it's uh it's one
where you have to sort of try and
visualize rather than just looking at
the uh the raw figures isn't it
chief executive uh chair thanks so it's
one of the
um it's probably worth just going back
giving a little bit of history and
context to it so historically when we've
had uh vet staff agencies because people
have left retired or Etc we would
wouldn't have ordinarily have filled
those vacancies because you'd go through
a recruitment process yesterday empty
for a period of time but the expectation
is you wouldn't bring short term
snapping other than in the operational
Services we could also need to send
Vehicles out etc etc so in operational
Services they have a separate budget for
agency staff Joe Richards able to pick
up the phone six o'clock in the morning
I need somebody because I need to send
the wagon out Etc
because of General recruitment
difficulties in the market obviously
what we can't do we'll Consular Newton
said was keep vacancies open for a long
period of time but more pressure the
team work doesn't get done etc etc so
we've kind of extended the use of agency
staff to cover our general vacancies
unlike the operational Services it does
go through an internal process through
our senior management team so we
consider whether that's appropriate use
of resources to fill that because as has
been indicated sometimes it's more
expensive so we have been monitoring
monitoring that and we've looked at the
figures currently the costs are of
employing agency staff to cover vacant
posts is less than the budget that's
accumulated
um
for one reason or one another because
there'll be different rates to pay for
different posts so it's something we
keep in a very close eye on and if you
recall
um at the CNR meeting not this week but
the previous one uh we allocated or
members approved the allocation of
additional resources to to potentially
subsidize the use of agency staff to
backfill where those costs have higher
are higher so we'd recognized that it
was a monitoring and keeping a very
close eye on so the team have done a
little bit of work to identify obviously
we know which posts are vacant which
have been covered so we've done that
exercise so at the moment we're
confident that the costs are providing
that external support are less than what
they would be if we'd had the individual
impulse obviously that post would have
been vacant for a period of time before
you've got agency staff in so it'll
depend the longevity of the the problem
being able to recruit
so hopefully that's a bit of a bit more
any other
comment on
salaries
overspend their agency staff FTE
good moving on
again Mr dengate Harbor income
as was established earlier by
partnering crime Mr Harper
there there are no big ships
and the question being is this a trend
of course this is largely what we're
trying to do with this exercise is spot
Trends rather than one-offs and
what is the Inc what is the overall
likely impact on the future
income from the harbor
um
the answer again from Richard Hayes is
that um uh it's in talks with very
shipping courage tourists to the era and
there is the hope there that that will
bring in more income to the harbor
um
views around the table any of
Biddeford views from
looking at the bit of a senior amongst
us where they're uh
I could have used the word Elder but uh
well I mean it's it's a tricky one I
mean there are
yeah a lot of people like to see more
ships in using the key I certainly would
I think it brings a a certain vibrancy
to the key when you've got uh you know
the clay ships and the timber ships in
but you know the trend over the last few
years has been less and less and less
and you know we are where we are we
can't uh
the very little we can do to actually
encourage
you know ships to come in and use it um
but I suppose there is always the other
argument
um do we want commercial ships do we
want as a commercial report or do we
want to use it uh try and encourage more
Leisure facilities coming into into
bitter Furniture I mean it is it is a
very emotive subject I think
I think that tends to be quite a
historical view on it often through Rose
tinted glasses as to um
what it was and what it is or can be in
the future are actually invariably quite
different things because excusing the
puns but the the Sams have shifted and
times have changed uh and
it's viability
for commercial work
just from the statistics I see here and
over the the recent years and having
looked at it again with in in a few
years ago
um must be really question the viability
of it and at what stage do you turn
around and say right fine let's put our
emphasis on actually a different use
um Catholic craigie first you were first
yeah I'd just uh like to say that
actually uh yesterday morning there was
a a meeting of the first sort of
Heritage Harbor sort of uh group of uh
organizations and chat in in the charity
sector and very much the Heritage Harbor
movement is about preserving existing
Harbors by embracing those alternative
uses uh exploration of of History the
educational side and the Leisure side
because it's recognized that those sort
of older ports in the country are no
longer sort of uh deep enough and with
with the facilities for the modern size
of commercial uh shipping and so that it
is looking at alternative ways of of
supporting it and there was quite a lot
of interest uh yesterday from a wide
range of groups to sort of continue to
explore and develop that idea
Council bushby again
thank you chair well you know one of the
issues we face is we are
the port authority
and whether we get
um large ships come up into the key like
we have historically still means that we
are still the horrible Authority and we
still have to provide the pilotage the
Harbor Master Etc because we still get
Ships coming at uh at Yellen so there's
quite a few commercial ships dock at
yelland that are still largely under our
responsibility so um you know we've
still got to bear the cost of
administering the service mainly even
though we don't get very many ships in
and that's clearly something that we're
going to have to consider going forward
if the trend for
very few Big Ships coming into the
harbor continues
um
Mr denke you've got follow up on that
yeah
just a couple of observations
um
why not it goes back to the earlier
conversation obviously if there's an
attractive key the Waverly would be
attracted to come in if there's not an
attractive key it might be less
attractive to come in just that was one
thought and we we've talked about it
going forward and looking at it it is
there perhaps a question as to who's
going to take it forward to actually
look at this because there was at one
point uh I think a review of this by the
harbor group I just wondered if there's
a another review where there's a need to
to look at it afresh with a view that
maybe the big ships aren't going to be
the owners and TCL way we can get to
break even
indeed I mean it's
I
and the issue is the linkage is is is is
is much wider than just the
worry about breaking even or not or the
commercial because it I mean go back to
pitches on the key it's all linked with
how you actually
used to the maximum modern benefit the
whole key side in Biddeford and
everything that goes with it and
actually is there a need to react to to
changing demands and needs and ways
um or are we just actually sat there
saying same old status quo and same old
thing but funnily enough it's not
happening
um and as you as you said also as well
because if it if it's a good place to
come to to just see it in in in
isolation
um
who should be
who should be who should or reads
looking at this
chief executive
um but there's a couple of angles
students that the harbor board we talked
about the Biddeford regeneration board
and we've got the Strategic plan so
they're all pieces of the jigsaw that
are already in place
um I kind of I can't remember Council
Bush was on the Harbor yes you are the
harbor board yes I thought you were but
I couldn't
um so on on the the bidford Regeneration
board as well so all of those
um have
needs and weighs in to developing ideas
for the father I mean the obvious thing
is that it's it I mean you're not
wanting to create yet more groups and
organizations I mean it's a hoverboard
thing but a hoverboard are you very are
you very commercially focused
at the moment yes it's probably
based on its historical use and moving
forward clearly that has to change we
have to look at the potential for
alternative uses of the keysight and
that's certainly something that the
Regeneration group you know would love
to see
who who chairs the harbor Boardman
I might have a chat with
um the chair of the harbor award anyhow
just uh to generally say that we've had
this discussion and aboard themselves
looking at
the bounds of what they look at and what
they're what they're trying to achieve
in in the modern day and age
um
thank you
moving on
um
budget monitoring
councilor bushby
um cracking in a question here
um
wanting the background
behind the contract cleaning and it
software overspends and the
um answer again from Gideon at the back
there
was that um
It software overspend largely
inflationary pressures and required
upgrades
um
which
ended up being more than what could be
estimated at the budget setting time
the cleaning budget the cleaning
overspend is is more identifiable
in that
um
the contract to uh a winning tender or
the winner of the 10 winning tender
that was the basis on which the budget
was forecast
that contractor then withdrew and to
replace uh the the service uh cost more
um so as a result a caretaker who
performed cleaning duties who's left
during the the period uh and um
that likewise has has required
um
more expensive cleaning effort happy on
that any questions uh functional answers
to a straightforward question uh for Mr
Harper budget monitoring
um
specifically asking two functional areas
legal and governance and communities in
place
um
why there was a budget shortfall at end
of year
and the answer there again from gradient
um
is that first of all the variances are
small
and the I I think the the answer to this
was covered in the highlights of the qbr
presentation anyway
um for instance legal and governance
um included 50 000 uh overspend on
hostels
um and um the 20 000 K under spend on
land registry
um
and also the impact of the pay award
um and a number of smaller
bits and pieces are you happy there Mr
Harper yeah good moving on local uh
economy
um from councilor Pennington
um
he was asking
and he produced
um some statistics which we can see
there
um
and this one was on numbers of Universal
Credit claimants
and he demonstrated with these figures
that
in torridge the the numbers had gone up
uh in Devon the numbers had gone up but
UK overall the numbers have gone down
and he asked the question why was this
happening in torridge when the national
picture was different
and the answer from Chris Fuller
economic develop statistics
one being underemployment
um including people working below their
skill levels and also the seasonal work
which masks uh realities of many figures
and
um
saying that that drives a focus really
on raising skill and salary levels
across the district's economy but it's
um I think we're all pretty aware of the
difficulties and the issues particularly
pertinent in in this area of the country
and indeed this type of
statistic is borne out in a number of
measurements of Social and economic
value where we know that we rate
low down down the overall table at the
moment for the various reason things
that we discuss from time to time
comment on that no
um
Mr Harper
asking about inward investment and the
floating offshay Shore array and how
will torridge benefit this is the
um
floating offshore wind farm in the
Celtics see
and again this will be Chris Fuller I
should think yes it is and he says that
um it's a big question very difficult to
provide an immediate answer for again
because there is so much out there which
is not known at the moment we are still
talking conceptual level and therefore
it really isn't that
um and um
much of it as he points out is based on
you know where that leases will go uh
what will be awarded by the crown of
State how significant oh he said
significant work is underway to
understand more in-depth opportunities
that might be presented for our ports
and harbors
um
I think did you go to the uh economic
Workshop day you missed a very good
um day actually unfortunately as many
storage counselors did
um and because we had a we had a a
in-depth presentation on all of this
area where we then looked at and were
shown
potential areas where we could pick up
business and and benefit from
um
obviously things like the maritime
Innovation Center and Harlem wolf
activity are are looking to play major
roles
um and we learned in that presentation
that the heavy lift side is almost
certainly going to come from ports in
the on the south Welsh Coast no one's
suggesting that that is going to come
from here but on the support side of
which this field will require Crews just
to service it
um that but there were some very
interesting statistics came out on the
the size of these things and how many
had to be produced and launched and
everything else and there was an
acceptance straight away that the heavy
side of it would was a business probably
for the Southwest coast and not a
councilor Craig who uh sorry who was
there
thank you very much
um you leave me speechless quite often
that one is one of your better ones
right
um
this is all a question of semantics
there's no uh bids were actually
received for these contracts so we are
again looking at a situation which is
still emerging and we need just to make
sure that toriage doesn't get left out
of the equations the work with Harland
and wolf is promising
and
um you know we're in close contact
thank you
it's a very difficult
one because as counselor Hodgson said it
a lot is not known
but if you sit on your hands for too
long saying well there's nothing there's
no detail out there and therefore we'll
wait until we know by the time you
actually know you know it because
actually other people have done done
deals made arrangements before it's
become public so the timing is key as to
at what point do you actually get out
there and start looking for proposed
seaweed Farm
and um
did you look at the their site there
yeah it's all good I mean
it would be because it's their site so
um they're marking their own homework
um and and um turkeys don't vote for
Christmas so um it's bound to be an
optimistic view I'm not suggesting that
it's wrong in any way but it's it's
um it's not an independent view
um your reaction to that Mr Harper
what I'm more interesting fact is at the
end of the day this is what they're
doing at the moment it's almost a trial
basis they haven't got the full field
yet therefore this is a new market and
it's it's quite a large Market what I'm
interested in as well is that we're
actually working with them to ensure
that torridge is actually engaged in
getting the best out of it so we
actually get to them the way in which
we're processing the seaweed but it
doesn't go somewhere else
and then lastly you pick up on what is
being widely said and that is that
there's an estimate Southwest Business
Council uh one estimate up to 20
reduction in visitors to the region and
you ask is that true for torridge and
the view from uh Chris Fuller our
economic development manager is largely
yes
um at this stage of the year of the
Season difficult to measure
statistically but by speaking to
um retailers and people in the business
there is a general view that numbers be
down
cautious of what Benchmark are you
comparing with
in that you know you've got to strip out
the covid years because they created
artificial data which is not safe to
compare with I know that from my own
business and therefore you've almost got
a crank back before covid and do your
comparison there there's too many people
in this business who are looking at the
Heyday of the covid year when actually
everybody had a staycation because they
couldn't go anywhere so we had a lot of
people down here everybody's very busy
and then they're trying to come on to
add to that
it's just that tourism is such an
important element within torrage
um it's it's we really ought to keep our
eyes on the ball rather than just
letting it slip and right I agree with
you yes the the indicators are not
comparable but nonetheless there is a
downturn
and clearly some people have actually
created a
um we've got the problem with with um
Airbnb and let's so I think you've got
that to look at as well and I've heard
that people now are actually turning
away from me
um as as as landlords because they can't
fill it
and that is a completely different
debate
um
and as a very difficult one to square
you know our two main industries are
tourism and that's the first requirement
is they have to have somewhere to stay
so you know uh careful you don't shoot
the goose that lays a golden egg
um Right Moving on
um
theme three our environment our future
councilor Pennington actually what he'd
done is he he'd stumbled or picked up on
didn't realize at the time that there
was a typing typo in the report that has
been corrected and therefore I there
isn't a comment on that and I've moved
straight on to questions from Mr Harper
Energy Efficiency asking about the ice
making machine at the fish dock which we
spent considerable amount of money on
quite recently
and wanted to know how much is it used
is it cost effective
Etc and there you see the answers
from Sarah Pennington Estates officer
um
and also she makes the point because Mr
Harper asks about fuel sales at the fish
dock and she says there are no fuel
sales
fish dog
um
I don't have a view as to whether that
is good or bad business on Ice sales
were you impressed with the answer Mr
Harper uh no
that this comes back from a very long
way ago where we actually took over from
the uh um Co-op of the fisherman's Co-op
and we actually did the the if I
remember rightly the ice machine and the
fuel at the same time we're now
replacing the the ice machine
um and if they're producing that much of
well the small amount of ice that's
there it surely can't be cost because it
doesn't answer the question it's not
cost effective surely
I mean
that's the obvious question from from
this and this response is what how much
does it cost
how much does it cost us to run it
ignore the capital cost where perhaps
we're not wanting to recover a
depreciation cost but what's the what's
the cost of running it and is
no idea because unless anybody has a
view how they
ah
I've got a viewer I've just got a query
it as to why Mr Harper feels why he's
asking that question is there is there
some underlying reason why he's asking
this or it seems a very strange question
foreign
I said right from the beginning is the
fact that we spent a lot of money over
the over the recent years in fact both
on ice machine and on fuel as I say the
fisherman's Cooperative we actually took
over and we put an awful lot of money
into it at that time we're now replacing
it again and there's a lot of money
going on and surely what we should be as
a council as sorry as a overview of
scrutiny is to actually look at the
finances and to actually ask the
questions and that's what I'm doing no
other reason so it's more a history in
in the fish dock site
the question actually
perhaps should have been more financial
orientated rather than actual material
things
um
the facts and figures that we've been
given there don't really
don't really mean much to us what we
want to know is actually is it running
is it is it washing its face is it
running at a loss is it actually
creating a small profit
Etc what is the cost of providing that
facility and we haven't actually got
that we might just
ask for that as a supplementary next
time please could we actually
um
yeah that that's fine although I guess
the the costs I would imagine to be
minimal because
um we're talking about 2 000 pounds
worth of income over a three-month
period
additionally I don't know whether the
ice machine is on a separate meter to
enable us to understand the electricity
cost of the ice machine because it's
very specific the question so I don't I
don't play much but I'm not 100 sure
well I would have thought that the the
machine itself would have a wattage that
it's drawing from it so that that yeah
yeah quite
um
be quite greedy if it's making ice I
think anyway whatever if it if it's
possible then we'd welcome that just to
actually properly answer the question
um finally
um no not finally because there's an
additional one Beyond it as well
um so see theme four again from
councilor Pennington
um
this uh which actually we talk about in
in a minute but he's talking about uh
enforcement uh here and
um specifically planning enforcement
and he's asking uh about
um
he's picked up on a number of
outstanding cases in the qbr which is
considerable which is caught our eye and
we're mentioning a minute and the
response is there from Helen Smith the
planning manager
um is that they are
putting a dedicated full-time an
additional
uh
the resource will be a dedicated
full-time offset and expected that
whether that's an additional officer to
what they had or not chair that's right
isn't it additional additional office
and as it says initially for a six-month
period because after six months or
coming up that period we then review
um how far and what dents we made in
that backlog before deciding whether or
not to continue
um so she says it will improve with with
a dedicated full-time officer coming in
um and then uh also
um councilor Pennington asks for the
instances or numbers of uh enforcement
action being taken
and there you see the the
um
uh
the chart
the most important part of all of this
actually Helen Smith makes a very good
point at the end uh where she said any
form of enforcement the
the ideal way is resolution through
negotiation
and
persuading the person who's transgressed
to actually get back within bounds and
not to end up going down the legal route
Etc or the procedural route and
therefore
a chart like that she makes a point
doesn't actually reflect the activity
that's going on in the background uh
indeed
um the because most of the activity
um hopefully has been successful in by
persuading people to
um
correct the the issues the answer to the
question it's something we can discuss
in a minute anyway any comment on that
man
right
uh
the next questions which were an extra
to this supplement from councilor bright
is that
announcer bright or the other counselor
bride
um
asking about whether
the covid initiatives and and
um
where they where the um
could we measure whether the various
covid initiatives and these are business
initiatives
um in the main
um we're having an impact
um
should the government be paying us extra
to administer this or are the government
already paying us extra
um I could say yes in terms of um what
we call it burden payments yes that's it
um
so
first of all uh
the point is made by uh so all of these
from Joe Wells Revenue benefits manager
that we haven't got it there aren't any
covered initiatives running now
although we still get lots of queries
from people which is obviously time
taken on staff
um and as we know because we used our
revenues and benefits team as well as
also members that uh
got passed to us for us to then
um get out to the various claimants
um
we took a bit of a we took a hit in
terms of processing our normal routine
work in terms of
benefits and revenues
especially and here it uses two examples
with housing benefits
and the
claims
and the processing or changes to housing
benefits in both those instances has now
reduced significantly as we've got past
the the impact on our staff
um
uh the um what you didn't um I don't
think she actually
covers exactly but as I said with the
chief executive there
um
in terms of government paying us yes we
were we were well well
we were reimbursed for the costs
um let's put it that way
um and uh you ask why uh council tax
collection rate down on last year
um
and that's offset with the additional
financial support for households to help
with Rising energy accounts so for
instance 150 pounds is paid to
households named been liable on council
tax accounts
um and they were protest in the majority
of time and
um
likewise with business rates
um the
it slips a little bit
um and therefore
um
uh this is reduced or withdraw after
they were reduced or withdrawn that
effects has a natural effect a human
effect on collection rate
Council bright you've got
um comment or follow-up on on the
responses there from Joe Wells
no not particularly I just wanted to
thank her for a speedy response because
I know it's a bit late in the day but
that was the opportunity I had to see
the report
um
but uh yeah so the the first one uh
about the benefits processing that's
mostly just backlog rather than an
actual covid Grant right because that's
how I read it was more that it was the
still dealing with covert grants or
something and I was like not we
the um you know is this the
also I just want to highlight that it's
still a worrying Trend to see that we're
seeing the decrease in business rate
collection you know it's not very good
for our local economy and I'm sure it's
probably a similarly National as well
I don't know how we can inflict
influence at our level
councilor bushby
thank you Karen again on the business
rate just a bit of a clarification
business rates have slipped slightly
and because again businesses are
struggling uh that's you know we we all
accept that
but that doesn't mean to say that the
business rates aren't
um they're not liable for business
rights
the fact that the collection rate is
down slightly does that mean that there
is now arrears on that side of things
if the business if we've got the server
amount of businesses that are still
liable for the business rates is what
I'm saying so if they haven't paid the
business rate that means there's an
arrear building up
yeah because they haven't they they have
an account just like you just like
council tax if you don't pull it pay the
full amount it it doesn't get written
off just because you haven't paid it it
it it becomes a a debt
um that um the council will then pursue
okay yes I I that's just correct and the
point being me that over those peers
during covid some businesses didn't have
to pay or have to pay a far less amount
of business raise because it was being
subsidized by government grants so now
as that's uh being reduced or removed
and businesses having to get back into
the uh the needs to pay their uh
business rates and that comes up which
we said if they're not paying they'll be
accruing as a race and the team will be
uh will be trying to recover though as
they do always with council tax benefits
on business roads
any other questions on that
good set of questions that
delving into different areas
um and provoking
some good chair just quickly before we
moved on in response to councilor
hodgson's question on the household
support fund so I managed to email Stacy
whilst uh we've been going through the
other questions
um so Stacy's responders saying we are
on track to spend with the applications
that are in the pipeline
um in terms of what we have to repay it
because the allocation costs that the
districts will spend
um if authorities were under spending
then that would cause a Devon wide
problem
so Stacy's involved in regular
monitoring meetings with other
colleagues across the Devon uh patch and
so money can be moved around if one area
is looking to overspend another is under
spending uh then they can the
reallocation process can take place but
the indications are we're on track to
spend the money anyway
very much for such a prompt to reply
during the meeting
okay
that ends the discussion of qbr
unless anybody else has any other
comment
I would particularly again thank
officers at all all levels
um Gordon and Tim and Clinton's gone but
and and all the other officers involved
in in providing
um uh responses that it's
um all time as we know that um takes up
uh okay
um moving to item 11 which again
um
on the work program we and in the last
meeting we discussed the potential of
looking or asking to look at
um
the whole area of enforcement
and we realized once we started to
discuss it in the last meeting that
enforcement actually can
what were we really wanting to talk
about the big ticket items like planning
enforcement or or Environmental
Protection
um but then
we started to get down to whole area of
the dog Wardens and what happens when
sort of you know
fouling of Pavements and it was uh
enforcement that and it we realized it
was a a huge air and was that actually
really what we were wanting to look at
um
the this
item was was raised by me anyhow
um and specifically my interest was
within the capacity of the planning
um area
um and as I said before
um
anywhere where you have a rule or
requirement you have to have a means of
monitoring stroke of persuading people
to actually comply effective or
ineffective or doesn't exist then people
start some people start to
take the same attitude with regard to
the whole need to comply with planning
Etc
and we could see even through the qbr
that the and was pointed out with one of
the questions just now that the backlog
or the outstanding cases we're doing
about 500 outstanding cases or um
there's considerable backlog and in the
planning world for everyone that we know
of here that's probably another 10 out
there that the council don't know about
um
uh and I think it's something that and
we I discussed it as it was a an action
point anyway I discussed it with the
chief executive uh and
um
also uh with John when we had our
meeting and I think we narrowed it down
to really the fact that at this stage we
we need to concentrate on on the big big
ticket items
um and that was obviously the planning
side but also the Environmental
Protection side because that is that
that is driven by by legislation as well
um and therefore
interesting uh enforcement within
planning is a discretionary task
it's it's not a statutory requirement
um the requirement to have a planning
organization is statutory but not not
the requirement to enforce it it all
seems a bit um strange to me
um
Environmental Protection
is is is is is statutory in the in the
in the in the sense that actually what
they're often there having to look at is
questions of Law and what is legal and
often determined in law as to what is
allowed or not so again it's a it's an
important area and I propose that
actually we
um
we seek to look at those two areas to
start with together and look for a
report in the future to to get a better
feel for
what is the real measure and size of the
problem
what is what is our capacity at the
moment or planned capacity and as a
result what do we think about it do we
do we then take a view that that is
satisfactory or not and is that going to
be a sufficient deterrent
to persuade people to conform with the
rules be it within the environmental
side or within the planning side because
that
from that could result in US
making a recommendation principally to
the chief executive because I would
think it would probably be a Manning
issue a staffing issue
if we felt that actually the council
were
underpowered in that area
um
but the upshot of that would be to
restrict it
purely to planning and Environmental
Protection at the moment because
otherwise if you try to go out to
everything else it just goes far too big
and too difficult at the moment and
those are two distinct areas where we
have
officers on that please
cancel Hudson
I think once you cannot ignore is the
financial implications of taking
enforcement action and the capacity of
your legal teams to put those
cases together
working with people so it's not just
about
understanding
what the regulations stipulate what
actions we can take we need to know the
knock-on effect on other services that
have got to work with them and the cost
and whether the authority whether the
members think the authority should
invest in these
and take because you don't win
necessarily every prosecution
on the costs
that are associated with those
prosecutions
is this Council for bold stance to drive
that forward and to allocate funding
if you're allocating funding you've got
to get it from somewhere it doesn't just
appear as a Magic Pot
so what aren't you going to do to be
able to do that so I think those are the
questions we really need to ask
I think at very
very uh good point made there that it
needs to be
all of the impacts and the knock-on of
course
we may also find or come to a view that
if we had greater capacity we're not
necessarily ending up as is as was
rightly said by by the planning manager
earlier in our questions qbr questions
doesn't necessarily end up with more
prosecutions and and more prosecutions
isn't isn't particularly a measurement
of success it but we need visibility of
cases that actually we've managed to
head off at the past and actually solve
without going to
the ultimate and quite there's a
financial cost and we have to have a
counselor has to have a view as to
whether it's prepared to pay that or how
it's going to pay it if necessary
Council Craig
yeah I think uh taking
um planning and Environmental Protection
the enforcement action on that is a it's
a very good start place to start because
it's uh that well the two most high
profile areas that uh any sort of
enforcement action is going to be taken
by the council so I think that's a very
good start and keeping it on that Focus
means that we can get a more in-depth
discussion of that yeah
councilor bushby
that I would agree with both of those
comments particularly when we're looking
at you know the larger higher profile
cases but we cannot ignore
the Grassroots
problems that we have around the town
because
with with with timely and proportionate
action taken by our enforcement team it
nips a lot of this into the bud and it
sends the right message out there to the
people that are
fly tipping that are dumping in in the
town I mean if we don't tackle it it
just gets worse and worse and worse and
we've seen that you know I'm seti a
fridge or whatever that's left just left
in the turn and people in the town there
are certain individuals that think it
perfectly acceptable if they've got an
old piece of furniture rather than
discarding it in a you know an
environmentally friendly way
at their cost they decide they're going
to put it outside the door push it down
the road a bit and the council will take
care of her and you know Richard's you
know fantastic with the team he always
responds but I always say to him try
your best to find out where it's come
from Richard and get environmental to
actually issue them with the penalty
charge and all this until we start doing
that with some success it will continue
I agree so
um
looking at those two particular areas
and as
councilor bushby said that I mean
Environmental Protection itself is is
quite a quite a wide area although they
are also closely linked with planning so
there is there is purpose in looking
those together our our councilors happy
that we restrict that to those two areas
Environmental Protection and planning to
start with that's not meaning that other
areas don't matter but
you've got to have some focus in it
otherwise it just be pointless and we we
um look for a a detailed report covering
those two where we actually want to
be able to see the and Come Away with a
good feel for the load of work the
amount of work and the way in which
we're able to deal with it and indeed to
have an officer present where we can
then have a dialoguing question and
answer perhaps in committee
Council bushby again
I'll give you one brief example we've
got a
I've got them on video twice doing that
I've reported it to our Environmental
Health Department
I'm asking for a reporter I haven't yet
had a report any feedback on it Devon
County Council didn't want to know about
it Southwest water didn't want to know
about it
environment agency said it's nothing to
do with them would I go with it so I
took it to our environmental team
who just happened to be visiting the the
said gentleman the following day on
another matter and I I copied the video
to them and I'm I'm hoping that she's uh
perfectly you know the evidence is there
you can't set water because it's grease
and oil
fat what are we going to drink that type
of thing allowed to continue just causes
man
[Music]
it's really good okay thanks uh I'm not
going to comment on a particular case
which I know nothing nothing about all
the the kind of legal things that need
to be done around that
um so members members obviously appear
to be accepting of those sort of figures
and obviously the
um
input of additional resources into the
enforcement teams who kind of got a
baseline
um obviously because we we reviewing the
qbr one the end of June
um qbr 2 will be the end of this month
so you wouldn't expect to see that
resource to have had a an impact so
might I suggest that we perhaps ask
um Helen Smith to report back
um to the committee Arc of time then to
a get somebody in post and B then start
with anticipate having an impact on that
that background with the the
Environmental Protection obviously we've
got a new environmental health and
Community safety manager
who's only just recently started so
perhaps if
the the trash Stacy uh Phil Gilbert I'm
the lead member and I meet first to kind
of have a discussion as to what
information to bring forward and then
consider at what point that would be
most productive for the team and
information to to members
everybody happy with that has outlined
by the chief executive
Council I'm I'm a bit concerned with
December
because we are going to be budget
setting and thinking about our budgets
in November and December
um is it a bit late in the day
to actually be trying to determine how
we might choose to influence that budget
um
I understand the reasons for December
however
I
I would hope that we could have some
information in November that we can
actually then come to some kind of
recommendations
um for full cancer
I think that's actually a very good
point because
the the upshot potentially the upshot
from our discussions and our
deliberation would be that
the council
is not putting enough emphasis on one
part or other of enforcement and
therefore our recommendation would be
um and decision as to whether
or not um
otherwise we're out of the cycle it's
not something that could be implemented
for another year
in that sense
um
if we asked for November chief executive
um try I personally I don't believe
December is too late because we
considering budget proposals in February
so from a December meeting
um you'd be you would be making
proposals to full Council they would
actually be to Community Resources which
would be a February meeting for
Community Resources so
um okay I'm sorry to disagree with my my
view that the December meeting
would be more appropriate
is your prerogative to disagree with me
um you know I just felt it was important
that we give ourselves time because
these things do tend to cause a great
amount of discussion and if we're having
to make choices between one area of work
that council members see as a priority
against another it might go backwards
and forwards a little and I always like
to err on the side of caution that we
give ourselves ample lead in time so I
still disagree with you I'm sorry we'll
talk about it later no doubt I hear your
your view Council Hudson as a
member of the budget remember working
group as well at
um
but I can see see there is that the
Merit in
giving sufficient time either a a for an
individual to bed in or secondly for for
the impact of new staff to to to be able
to be seen uh otherwise we're slightly
stabbing in the dark not not knowing
um
I I would personally uh with the chief
executive and say we we aim for the 12th
of December but I would also say that
I'd aim to although we would have a
discussion to just to agree the limits
of the Environmental Protection One that
we'd want to look at both in the 12th of
December one there's no point having
again if something no point having it
any later than that
if we could ensure we schedule a meeting
before the 7th of November meeting at
least then we'll be able to update the
committee of what's happening and
ultimately also I don't never like to
suggest that you could always call an
extra meeting should the need arise or
move a meeting that's already in the
timetable to facilitate a more timely
um report and recommendation should
there be one we are of course ever
flexible keeping things
um
that being the case I propose that
um the uh we call for a uh report as
we've discussed concerning enforcement
within the
local planning Authority area and also
within Environmental Protection the
detailed Environmental Protection to be
fleshed out a bit more with Chief
Executive myself
um is that something we need to to vote
on we think uh I'm happy to propose on
that and uh councilor Craig is second
going to have a show of hands in support
of that as a item coming forward
uh
that is whatever one two three four five
six seven eight nine
and against
and won against
and there's nobody left to abstain
um
no no because we don't have recorded
votes here so there's no problem
um
the um
thank you for that
um and that takes us straight to the
consideration of the forward plan page
42 on the um uh agenda documents
and therefore you we can immediately
drop into cycle six uh which is on the
12th of December into that meeting the
um
enforcement capacity within planning and
Environmental Protection let's say that
for the time being
um
coming back to the
forward plan
um I met with the chief executive and
John and indeed Gordon
a while ago and we looked at
um
various elements and as you can see that
that's on that one do we
yeah yeah so quite correct so on the 7th
of November there cycle five as well as
qbr 2. we're looking at the Strategic
Asset Management plan
and
as well which with Q always remember qbr
and the questions if they're good ones
will take the Lion's Share of a meeting
on the 12th of December
um
we are going to actually review the qbr
process
and
um there is going to be a
member
um
questioner going out ahead of that that
John has in hand
um
and that's very important that is the
first
review of the actual process since we
did a major rewrite
two years ago three years ago Stephen
how long ago did we rewrite the qbr
format three years ago and
um
just to to look at and satisfy ourselves
whether it's actually doing what we want
it to do
um and um we've also got the northern
Devon you can economic strategy build
for that day
um
6th of February cycle seven is a budget
special
so
that's not a blank column it's very full
column with budgeting
um
went into qbr 3
and then the draft Estuary strategy at
the moment we've got into April next
year
um
comment on that please
and looking at the bottom under review
there we've got the asset management
plan we've we've already
um just spoken about that
um
these were some of the key things that
we picked out of the work program
homelessness strategy Grounds
Maintenance recruitment in attention
retention
um
the northern Devon economic and Estuary
strategies really
um
we talked about discretionary versus
strategory spends which is largely a
budget working group thing
um
child poverty
we really thought was
um
in the main an external thing
and enforcement which we've just we've
just touched on talked about
um
have you got anything on your chart
that's for later in the uh no chair
obviously you've just pulled off two
items of the keep under review Into Your
yeah program so
um I guess it's for the next meeting to
review yeah
um our members happy
um with that as printed and now we've
got
um as as we said we've got the Strategic
um
asset uh plan Asset Management plan on
the uh November meeting to come in
um and in December we've got the
enforcement categories to come in
um
February spoken for is budget anyway and
there will be other things to come in
later in the thing
um are members happy with that as it
stands
councilor craiged
yeah definitely uh very happy with that
sort of workflow but I wondered if there
was any sort of indication when the
homelessness strategy might be sort of
being put into the
be ready to be scheduled into the scheme
for that
I've got a date for that yeah that's why
I suggested as we go through the
meetings then we'll consider when
councilor Hodgson
however the homelessness strategy is a
statutory requirement yes so we we can't
lose sight of that now what I was going
to say when are we going to be looking
at the corporate strategy
that we are formulating now should we
not actually put some time aside for
that
well the whole Council will be looking
at that as a counselor so you wouldn't
ordinarily
it's do that as a separate piece of work
because the way it's been designed
obviously we had the workshop which
the 30-ish
[Laughter]
your your ration of descent is used up
um
it's an interesting point because folk
or I I absolutely agree that progression
it doesn't involve us but in in other
instances
full Council itself is not a is not a
scrutiny body
full Council you don't get the
opportunity to actually have the
discussion we have here or or or uh so
it it's full council is not actually
scrutinizing at that stage and that is
why at times
um it does make perfect sense for us to
look at something before for Council
look at something because we actually
can spend more time delving into it or
asking questions which that opportunity
doesn't appear once you get into a full
council meeting people say oh it's
signed off full counts have done it they
signed it off they haven't actually had
the opportunity to
um get amongst the weeds a bit which
hopefully we can but thank you yes
um
so are we we haven't had an answer on
that yet on the homelessness strategy
and
was the upshot from that that we should
be looking at homelessness separately
from the overall housing because of its
statutory nature or not
we can't lose sight that it is a
statutory requirement but we are looking
at a overarching housing strategy of
which one of the key documents would be
the homelessness strategy so work is
being undertaken at the moment I've only
recently become lead member for housing
but it's an area of great interest to me
so we will be working quite closely with
the leader of the council who's been
doing an enormous amount of work with
John Walter and drawing all those
aspects
um
of the work of the housing team of
development of opportunities for funding
all those things have got to be pulled
together in one document about how we
wish to proceed
to minimize homelessness to address
those issues and to keep control of our
budgets so it's all it's all part of
that documentation so it will be a
considerable piece of work
and I think because we've decided to
embrace it with the overarching homeless
housing
it might take a little bit longer than
we'd anticipated but I have not had
those meetings yet as John Walter is in
foreign parts or wherever uh you know
I'm sure when he comes back he's going
to be delighted that not only is he
doing the corporate strategy but he's
he's working on this as well but so much
work has been done I think it is a
question of pulling it together in a
document and I'm sure the officers will
support us not Not For a Moment putting
you on a spot but
um
do you have an aspiration as to when
in your own mind you have an aspiration
as to as to when you're aiming for would
hoping that actually you might be in a
position to have a
document or at least a draft together
that can start to be people can have a
look at now I'm going to be in trouble
with the chief exec if I put a time
limit on this I would personally
anticipate that we should be able to get
something around
[Laughter]
is that a reasonable expectation Chief
exec please
put me on the spot now is this spot's
going going around
um yeah I don't think we've kind of sat
as cancer hotter sat down and kind of
thought right we need this is what we
need to do this this this and that so I
think we before we kind of pin ourselves
down today we ought to have that
discussion and I guess in terms of
aspirations I I was looking at a lot of
times I was expecting Council Hudson to
say next Friday or something like that
why don't we as a provisional
put into
March next year
or April next year
yeah well we um we are
in February we are budget and therefore
our next meeting would be March and I'd
quite like to
even if you know reasons may be but if
we don't actually start to put in I
would think it would be important to
actually have it before the budget is
agreed because there may be budgetary
implications from this strategy
so
um
again I'm
making assumptions here
but I would have thought
um
we don't have a meeting in do we have a
meeting in January we don't have one
scheduled and and the February one is
taken up with budget if if it was that
important we could easily create we can
we can put a meeting in um
quite we need to see it when it's in
draft form so so that we can therefore
be constructive in assisting with it um
and as councilor Hodgson said it needs
to be done at a time if there's going to
be budgetary implications then
but
there's lots of other things going on
yes counselor as with all strategies
there is a period of consultation and
this committee will be obviously one of
the Consultants
good thank you very much
I have one other item which actually I
should brought forward yeah and that is
that
just whilst we're on the floor plan can
I just make an observation go on yeah
cycle eight
um for the harbor Estuary that that's
reporting back on the recommendations
this committee made I think that's
writing saying that that's going into
the economic strategy I just wonder if
that's also an area for your
conversation with the chair of the
harbor ball to land and whether that
might be a good Focus to aim for
on the um on the Estuary strategy
and on the discussions we've had today
a good point thank you for that
um
the last point which probably should
have been brought up as items under the
chair
um but it
proposed by councilor bright
um
he's made the observation that
uh we have reports of
many of our electric charging points
being out of action
um